boy do we all miss Whitney Houston you
know 35 years ago her debut album became
a summer sensation and et was with her
through it all I believe my mom took me
the studio and I've been working
professionally since I was 12 years old
[Music]
I'm living it out right now this is part
of the doing whatever happened sky's the
limit
[Music]
but the time will come I want to have a
family and I want to get married and I
want to have a Korea and have a husband
and have a family you know that kind of
thing but roadways from this even at 21
years old
Whitney was all about goals and from the
recording booth to a guest starring role
on silver spoons
we were right there as she made her
dreams come true
her debut album took two years to make
sold more than 22 million copies spent
14 weeks at number one on the charts and
produced three number-one singles I was
just blessed with a kind of a power that
comes from my lungs and I have lungs
just like everybody else but it's just a
different kind of power that comes from
my body
Whitney's mom Cissy had a big role in
the video for greatest love of all and
remember this nine year old girl who
played young Whitney well her name is
Kiara Haley Gordon she's 43 now and a
drama teacher living in New Jersey I
think she realized how nervous I was you
know she came up to me hugged me and I
stopped crying immediately and she said
you know everything will be all right
baby
out of 300 girls at auditioned she chose
me the one moment that really sticks
with me is the scene near the end where
we walk across the stage and I dissolve
as we meet in the middle
greatest love of all is featured on
Whitney's debut album which is being
re-released in a special two discs vinyl
collection today the album was nominated
for a Grammy and we were with the
nervous singer as she and her parents
got ready for the big night it comes and
it goes you know it's like I'm like
butterflies you know it leaves you don't
think about it that night Whitney took
home gold I feel great I feel good I
really do
God gave me something really great and
he doesn't give it to everybody
[Music]
and here it is at 35th anniversary
edition my gosh she looks so gorgeous
here remember this photo
[Music]